so they basically looked at it and said
okay
lucy hale this script we think it's this
much money we can make off of it so this
is what we'll offer it to you
and so even then they don't give you the
money to go make it you then have to
still find someone else to usually
finance that that contract basically
it's almost like collateral you use to
kind of then go make it
if we took your pitch
how much
was about the idea of the film and how
much was about the return on investment
i think it's probably
a 50 50 kind of pitch in terms of the
creative side and the financial side i
mean obviously depends on who you're
pitching
um when it's an actor or something like
that it's all about the character and
all about the story when it's an
investor it's much more on the financial
side but hopefully the people you're
working with do care about making a good
movie and that was the case in my case
but ultimately making movies is a
business and unless you could finance it
yourself
you have to kind of work within that
system and
i felt confident though that this film
could be financially successful because
it wasn't some sort of quiet indie drama
it was a really compelling
um
kind of commercial film but with a lot
more to it you know so if you look at
the trailers that the distributors made
it's it's a very commercial version of
the movie it's actually it's almost
um
it's a it's a lot more depth than in the
film when you when you actually watch it
but they are able to market it like a
broader kind of commercial action movie
you know and that's going to bring
people in and when they watch it they're
going to hopefully be pleasantly
surprised there's actually so much more
to it it's not so much that it really is
a much deeper complex film and so but i
knew that that's how you could do it and
that would that would be a model that
would work and so
um we also the movie is not a very
expensive movie and we
we made it for as little as budget as
possible and we put a lot into it and
we were able to make a really great
looking film
um on a pretty small indie budget still
and so i think it's in a place now where
because of all that i think it will
hopefully make its money back and be
successful and um
you know i think it's it's it's an
interesting size film that i think
we could be doing more of these kind of
um couple million dollar films where
um
you know it it has
uh this blending of genres and worlds
where there's there is some risk still
because
um you're trying to tell maybe a more
deeper story but
um
it's not just this
i think we hollywood needs to take a
little bit more risk but there could
also be some calculated risks like this
you know which is
uh not everything has to be some sort of
sequel or remake or whatever like there
is there are sizes of films that still
make sense where
it's it still could make its money back
it still has a good shot at being a very
successful film um but it's still
telling a new fresh original story with
a unique cast you know and maybe really
almost first time director so
um i hope it's it'll be a i hope if it's
successful it'll prove and show that um
they can be taking more chances on
people like me
how much do investors care about movie
ideas movie ideas
i mean i think if it's a good investor
they they care about the idea and the
the concept um certain investors don't
care at all and they just want to see
who's in it and what the genre is and
you know what the
the dollars and
all that stuff is you know what is a tax
incentive and all that kind of things
and unfortunately that's how a lot of
movies get made but that's also why we
end up with a lot of not so good movies
too so i think the best case is when you
kind of think of it from both sides you
you obviously need to understand this is
a business it has to make money and have
a shot of that but you still have to
make a compelling good movie otherwise
what's the point because we're only
doing this to entertain people and make
good stories so
um
i was lucky to have investors that
wanted to make a good film um
and so hopefully you know that's where
people want to kind of go towards when
you're
when you're trying to make your film i
definitely met with people who didn't
have that that vision you know and
and i didn't make the movie with them
you know so i think it is
about trying to be patient and and
you know i probably could have made the
movie a little bit sooner if i had made
more compromises creatively um
but
i was pretty clear on certain things
specifically authentic cast and
um making the film in a certain style
and in actual real locations you know
that that fit the story and
um you know not shooting in new mexico
or something that just fit totally out
of place you know just because it had a
good incentive or something and so it
definitely probably took a little bit
longer but in the end it made a really
great film by kind of holding out a
little bit longer probably
so from your experience in 2003
when you were a teenager and you made a
feature
do you think the
concept the idea was important at that
time to those distributors versus now
it's it's just much different it's a
machine
[Music]
um well so i think that first feature i
made when i was
in high school
it got picked up from a distributor
because i think they could tell a bigger
story by
this 17 year old had made a feature film
like that's kind of was the selling i
was the star of that movie i guess you
know
um so i don't think it's changed a whole
lot
obviously there's there's more and more
opportunities now for distribution than
ever and so
um i still think there's lots of
opportunities and there's lots of smart
good distributors that want to make good
things
but
um
unfortunately there still are a lot of
movies that are made more from the
financial only sense and not just is
this a really good movie that's gonna
um people are gonna enjoy because i
think also people
they when sometimes when they analyze a
movie only from the money side they
forget that the creative is a money side
too you know like if the movie's crap
then
it doesn't mean the movie's gonna be
successful just because it fits
everything else you know and so
and if you make a really good film it'll
still probably
it can still be successful so i think it
still should all be it should be all
around the story and the script
unfortunately it isn't but hopefully
um more films are successful of this
kind of size that are like that that
hopefully that can that can change some
things
okay so you have a name attached you
have someone who has a fan base
then how how does the money then follow
yeah so
i had
written the script i had made this proof
of concept i had gotten lucy hale
attached to star in it um and then it
still took two years to go make the
movie after that
so yeah because we still had to find the
money um
basically we had her value now which
gave the movie
an actual way to kind of have value to
for people to see that it could make
money once it got made but we still had
to get people to to commit to a certain
dollar amount we had to then just find
the actual people that wanted to invest
in that
um our model was
after
you know so lucy she signed on she
actually kind of came on also as an
executive producer to kind of say hey
i'll help you try to go get this made
too a little bit
and so she sent the script to a producer
he came on board to help me he was
excited about it he took it some more
producers
you know that's kind of how it always
works right it just kind of goes on to
the next person um they eventually were
able to get us uh it's called an mg or
minimum guarantee and it's basically a
distributor pre-buying the movie before
you even made it just off the script and
the cast so they basically looked at it
and said okay
lucy hale this script we think it's this
much money we can make off of it so this
is what we'll offer it to you
and so even then they don't give you the
money to go make it you then have to
still find someone else to usually
finance that that contract basically
it's almost like collateral you use to
kind of then go make it
so that's how we did it that was our
model um
and so
you know that's that's how we were able
to get the movie made um
and
yeah i mean it's it it still took a long
time and you know this was also like
right
you know we were supposed to go make the
movie or hoping to go make the movie and
then cope it happened so that pushed
just off again and had another delay and
so
you know it's um
it's just never and even when you think
it's all put together or something falls
apart you know and so it's it's a whole
process i was a producer on the movie
but my other three other producers were
really the key people in terms of the
financial side so they were really the
ones getting that money and putting that
together and and managing all that so
you know i can't speak to all of it in
super detail but it's definitely a
complicated process that is uh
you know it's
it you never know what's gonna happen
next basically with it
so the fact too that lucy hale was an
executive producer and was sort of
helping to shepherd the movie probably
was incredibly helpful as well for sure
i mean having her name attached as an
actress is huge but then having her as
vouching for it as as a really strong
project that she wants to put her weight
behind was was super essential i mean
just legitimized the project and um
opened more doors you know i mean it's
funny though even when you have someone
famous attached it could still be really
hard it's just so hard to get a movie
made you know no matter who it is trying
to to make it i think
uh they they make it as difficult as
possible you know and uh but i think if
you just keep going and never give up it
it it will usually find a way
were there any things where let's say
you were all boarding a plane ready to
film and
something fell through
um luckily we didn't have anything fall
through too late in the game i think the
biggest thing was just we shot the film
in spain um we ended up doing that
because
we we had to basically the time window
we were going to originally make this
was in the spring of 2020 which of
course was when covid was coming and
shutting the world down
so then
we had this window in the fall when we
thought we could go make it somewhere
because the world was starting to open
up again at least in europe
but after we waited too long lucy and
other people might not be available
anymore
so we knew if we were going to make it
this year as in 2020 when we made it um
we had to go then and the only place we
could really do that was
was not in california where we were set
because everything was still so much
more closed down to get the permits at
the state park and everything were
already going to be complicated but even
during covet it was just almost
impossible and so
i had been looking at other countries
and places to film the movie before this
even
just to kind of to explore what
opportunities there were
and spain has this desert that looks
almost identical to california desert to
the desert of anzarego where the movie
is set
and that was not my first choice
originally and it's not what i ever
thought was the right move to go all the
way to spain just to make the movie
that's set here but it ended up being
probably the perfect thing because the
desert it was such a perfect match and
then it allowed us
our money actually went a lot further in
spain because one is there's a tax
incentive for the whole country for
filming but then just the crew and other
things that the money i think it allowed
us to get probably even more for our
money i mean you obviously lose money
too on exchanging to euros and flying
people over there and all that stuff but
in the end of the day we found a great
group of people that wanted to help us
make this movie and and we made a really
great film there and so
um it all worked out but i think yeah
the
to your particular question it was the
hardest thing was probably just getting
the visas for people to get over there
allowing even the airlines didn't want
us
and to get on the plane like because at
the time no one was traveling even you
know americans weren't allowed to travel
and so
you know the first plane i tried to get
on leaving lax they wouldn't let us on
the plane because they were worried we
wouldn't be allowed into the country you
know because it was just such a rare
thing for people to be leaving the
country
so there was those kind of complications
but once we were there you know it was
just the typical normal complications of
just trying to figure it out but um
luckily there weren't any sort of major
drama or anything like that
so you had your boarding pass and maybe
a carry-on and they said sorry sir we
can't have you yeah no we were trying to
check in uh for the plane um
to go to spain and go film a movie and
we had a ticket and everything but the
actual you know agents checking our bags
in basically said like you know you're
not
you
you don't have you're missing some
pieces of paperwork or whatever we
didn't we had it but they were just so
had never experienced this yet that
an american was leaving the country
you'd go make a movie somewhere that
that would be allowed by the spanish
government you know and
so it was just it was just so new to
everyone you know no one this was in
september august september of 2020 was
just still so so fresh still in the
middle of the pandemic really
you